Peter King NBC sports.com the football
morning in America NFL columnist and I
saw Peters got his postseason
predictions here Peter good morning how
are you good morning Dan how are you I'm
doing okay
the most controversial pic that you have
for the postseason this year is probably
the Colts winning the sell and Jacoby
Brissette being an MVP candidate Wow
okay why are you all in on the Colts I'm
all in on the Colts as a team the last
time we saw Jacoby Brissette play
according to pro Football Focus they
have the 25th best offensive line play
in football and Jacoby Brissette was
chased all over creation that was in
2017 last year when when Andrew Luck
played they had the third best offensive
line performance in the NFL and that is
the offensive line that Jacoby versed
will play behind right now along with I
think a significantly better defense
than he had in 2017 and so I just think
he's going to have an opportunity to be
the beneficiary of a much better team
around him we'll see where that takes
them I realize that losing luck should
be like losing a couple of wins a year
and I get that I don't argue with it at
all but then here's the way I look at it
the last three years seven seven and six
new playoff teams from the previous year
have made the postseason and even though
Indianapolis obviously made the
postseason last year wouldn't be one of
those I believe that every year that you
make picks you've got to take some shots
otherwise why don't you just pick what
it was at the end of last year and my
you know look my Super Bowl pick is
Kansas City in New Orleans and they were
both in the Final Four last year too so
it's probably either Indianapolis or San
Francisco making the playoffs over
Dallas and
Seattle that would have people saying
King you're out of your mind
so anyway I'm I'm kind of used to that
what's your what's your big question
mark with the Cowboys I know Zeke not
being there but assuming he'll
eventually show up what is your big
concern I think my big question mark is
you know after the easiest beginning of
the season that anybody in the NFL has
Giants at home Washington on the road
Miami
I think Miami at home if I'm not
mistaken but I mean they think that they
have a simple for is simple relatively
speaking with or without Zeke if they're
not two-in-one after three weeks this is
going to be an awful season for them at
least two and one
and so but after that they really got a
tough schedule and I and look
everybody's got a tough schedule but I
just wonder what happens to this team
when I mean can you sign everybody are
you going to sign Amari Cooper you're
gonna sign dad Prescott you're gonna
sign Zeke you sign al Collins today I
mean how many near top of market
contracts at their position can the
Dallas Cowboys sign and I'm not saying
they're doing the wrong thing I'm
definitely not but are they going to get
all these guys done and if they don't
what is going to be the what's going to
be the hangover effect to the guys who
either don't get done and then there
will be others that we haven't even
thought of who are saying hey what about
me talking to Peter King go through all
your picks your preset your post season
picks the Patriots Steelers Indianapolis
in Kansas City my wild cards are the
Chargers in Houston and then in the NFC
I've got the Eagles I got the Packers
beating the Bears
I've got New Orleans winning the south
and Rams winning the West and the two
oiled cards being Chicago in San
Francisco and I've got
New Orleans in Kansas City advancing to
the Super Bowl Kansas City winning it
explain to me what the Texans have done
here in the last couple of days well I
think that when they kick off Monday
night in New Orleans they will be a
better team not a significantly better
team but a better team than the ones
that ended last season and the reason is
that no team in football needed a left
tackle and needed an offensive line
improvement than more than the Houston
Texans and you know deshaun Watson got
killed last year behind that line and I
think the reason they ended up paying a
ransom for Laremy Tunsil and Kenny
Stills was very very simple but I think
I think that that bill O'Brien said I am
NOT entering this season with the same
hopeless offensive line that I had last
year and so look I do I cannot in any
way defend not signing Laremy Tunsil
to a contract before he did this deal
and make no mistake about it if you call
Laremy Tunsil and his agent and
basically say hey in the next five hours
you've got either except five years 90
million with 50 million guaranteed or
whatever the number is it's all monopoly
money you either have to accept that or
we're not going to make the trade and
you can play the next two years for 12
million or whatever he's going to make
so that that that would be a powerful
motivator to a guy like Laremy Tunsil is
already thinking he got job done draft
night because of the bong incident
pushing him so far down in the draft so
that's where I fought them I do not and
I think they slightly overpaid slightly
for Tunsil and for Kenny Stills but just
remember one in two ones in the two but
just remember if you pay the twentieth
22nd and 54th overall picks to solve
your left tackle problem for the next
ten years I think it is board
line word that it's a little bit rich
for my blood but I don't think it's an
absurd payment the Patriots just seemed
to continue to be the Patriots I know at
some point they stopped being the
Patriots the artist formerly known as
but what is it about this year with the
Patriots that is going to be different
than any other year I don't really think
anything you know no one no one in the
AFC East has risen to the level of a
legitimate challenger to the Patriots so
I don't think they're in any trouble in
their division I mean I think they've
got a good chance again to win it I you
know I can't it's hard for me to make a
counter-argument other than Gronk is not
there they really haven't solved their
tight end problem and you know and Keele
Harry who should have been ready to help
from the jump he's not going to be ready
to help from the jump now because he's
hurt so I there's all these reasons that
you could say well look out for the
paint you know look out for the Patriots
downfall I don't buy it for a second I I
mean I think that they've got a good
chance to win I mean you know in my
position
I'm not picking the Patriots every year
I picked them to make the Super Bowl
last year with the Rams right on this
weekend of last year I was right I very
rarely want to make a duplicate pick but
having said that could I make a
legitimate argument for the Patriots to
win it in absolutely and how amazing is
it by the way then that in the year the
NFL plays its 100th season 20% of those
seasons 20% a featured Bill Belichick
and Tom Brady being together it's just
it's one of the most amazing stories in
NFL history it'll never happen again
never never no coach is going to coach a
quarterback for 20 years and in the 20th
year everybody how crazy is it that no
one would be shocked if they want
another Super Bowl certainly not you or
me if the Browns don't make the playoffs
this year finish that sentence
if the Browns don't make the playoffs
this year I didn't pick them to make the
playoffs if they don't make the playoffs
this year and they go six and ten it
will be a crushing disappointment if
they don't make the playoffs they show
significant progress go nine and seven
and are the second best team in in their
division or ten and six and and get
edged out of a playoff spot I think
it'll be a massive success I mean B and
I just one of the reasons why I'm on the
Browns bandwagon but I'm not leading it
is that you know this is a team there's
going to be no team in the first month
of this season that will be as famous as
in-demand as public as the Cleveland
Browns they're playing three prime time
games in the first five weeks of the
season and the first month of the season
three prime time games Monday Sunday
Monday and I'm not saying that that is
debilitating or run I'm just simply
saying that other than maybe Morgan
Burnett I'm probably trying to probably
forget somebody is safety that the
Browns have now I mean how many of those
guys on the team have been playing big
games in late January I don't I just you
know or how many guys have been really
been in the spotlight O'Dell certainly
but I you know this is just not a team
that is used to what is about to happen
to it maybe it means nothing I I don't
know maybe that'll be able to keep
normalcy the whole year and and plus I
think the one other things that caused
me that just have second thoughts is
that Odell Beckham jr. is a great player
but in the last two years he's been hurt
both years and I'm not saying he's
injury prone because he wasn't hurt his
first couple of years in the NFL his
first three years so I I'm not saying
that this is this is a trend and he you
know he can't stay healthy I'm not
saying that I'm just saying that I'm not
positive that he's gonna give him 16
barnburner games how often do we see
teams that and I'm sure Miami doesn't
like you know the definition
of their tanking but it feels like
they're tanking how many how many times
can you remember where you thought a
team was actually tanking well the only
other one in recent history I think is
Cleveland when they were acquiring all
the picks this one just feels a little
bit different to me because first of all
you know I would say zaevion Howard is
the best individual player on that team
they haven't traded him now it you know
it's you know check back by 4:00 today
or tomorrow I don't know I have no idea
what they were going to do but but so
maybe Howser
their second best player I would argue
was probably Laremy Tunsil and who's a
top six or seven left tackle in the NFL
and he's 25 years old
I understand trading for the future and
getting all these picks and dumping
Kenny Stills for whatever you get for
him I get it I get that but explain to
me why you're trading a 25 year old left
tackle who's pretty good you know that
one that one doesn't make sense and that
one I think and again maybe something's
going on behind the scenes that I don't
know but even though they got a lot for
him at some point you got to use those
picks and I had a stat in my column
yesterday that over the next two years
in the first and second round Miami's
got eight choices Houston has one but I
also know that now Houston does not have
to worry about it assuming they sign him
at some point Houston doesn't have to
worry about one of the four or five most
important positions in the game left
tackle and Miami certainly does yeah
because you're gonna tank for twoa to is
probably gonna want to know who's my
left tackle now granted being
left-handed he might want to know whose
right tackle is but you have a very
talented young offensive lineman and
that's that's what surprised me there
and as you pointed out it's one thing to
have draft picks it's another thing to
use them wisely
you know the Cleveland Browns were not
the Baltimore Ravens now we're gonna see
if Miami has the
the structure to be able to capitalize
on all those draft picks but if you're
tanking for tua and in my in my column
yesterday I wrote that between 2014 and
2017 that the Browns you know in those
four drafts they had 13 picks you know
in the first three round or in the first
two or first three rounds
excuse me first three rounds and out of
those 13 picks only three of them are
currently starting for the Cleveland
Browns I mean so and again I'm not
saying that Miami is going to be that
bad I don't I don't have any idea what
they'll do but it's easy to eat it's
easy to get the picks not easy but it's
a lot easier to get the picks then to
giraffe stars with them so we'll see how
they do
Thank You Pete we appreciate your time
as always
Peter King NBC sports.com and of course
his column as they must read football
morning in America for more Dan Patrick
show tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]